palmes masques bouteille combinaison
chauffantes et un flotteur pour signaler
sa présence sous l'eau nathalie lasselin
se préparent à plonger dans le
saint-laurent tout l'hiver elle a suivi
un entraînement spécial pour réaliser en
septembre une plongée de 70 km dans le
fleuve
d'un bout à l'autre de l'île de montréal
je m'en vais au bout du monde faire des
grandes expéditions mais en est un qui
est juste là à vingt minutes du
centre-ville puis c'est ça qui est
extraordinaire dans un petit peu comme
les explorateurs mais des temps modernes
je vais parcourir le fleuve mais dans
l'autre sens je vais y aller avec le
courant puis voir ce qui se passe là
dessus elle documente et une expédition
extrême qui ne sera pas la première de
nathalie lasselin sept plongeurs
professionnels explore depuis 18 ans
tout ce qui est sous l'eau et sous la
terre des mers chaudes aux océans glacés
des grottes sous marines aux rivières
souterraines des épaves au banc de
requins
elle vient est intronisé au temple de la
renommée des plongeuses une belle
reconnaissance professionnelle pour
cette passionnée qui a donc décidé
d'explorer le saint laurent autour de
montréal l'été dernier elle a réussi une
première plongée de 21 km dans le fleuve
entre le pont jacques-cartier et l'est
de l'île six heures sous l'eau achetée
fonds se font plus ça avançait plus
j'étais émerveillé donc je suis très
concentré sur mon azimuts la dir est
changée j'essaie de voir partout ça va
très vite y est les rochers puis quand
je suis arrivé à la fin je me suis dit
ok je les fais j'ai vu il ya
effectivement énormément de choses à
documenter va falloir que je revienne
la plongée de 70 km doit se faire à la
mi septembre quand les conditions seront
maximales pour assurer sa réussite
nathalie lasselin prévoit passer entre
30 et 40 heures sous l'eau sans en
sortir va se nourrir d'aliments liquides
et dormir dans le fleuve est resté sous
l'eau parce qu'on peut réussir on peut
attendre des des objectifs
incroyable on peut réussir de grandes
choses si on s'engage pleinement dans ce
conflit
au-delà de cet exploit phuc nathalie se
donne aussi la mission de faire des
prélèvements qui seront analysés par des
scientifiques pour évaluer l'état de
santé du saint laurent est un
documentaire va raconter cette odyssée
urbaine aquatique pour accompagner la
plongeuse dans les profondeurs de notre
fleuve et c'est catherine françois radio
canada montréal